will the Federal Reserve go to war with
President Trump should America stop
detaining illegal immigrants is a
lesbian dating a transgender man now
straight all of these questions and more
will be answered on this episode of the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
I'm not kidding we're actually gonna
answer that last question or at least
the Washington Post is going to try to
because the media are our Guardians and
our firefighters everything's going
swell in America guys so let's just jump
right into the news apparently the key
yield curve has now inverted to the
worst level since 2007 so that's some
good news to brighten up your morning in
your afternoon thirty-year rate has now
dropped under two percent according to
CNBC long term Treasury rates added to
their month-long slide on Tuesday
aggravating a key yield curve inversion
and sending the 10-year yield to its
lowest level against the 2-year rate
since 2007 in other words everybody in
the world is buying long-term bonds
they're trying to store their money in
long-term bonds because they do not have
a lot of faith in the short-term economy
the yield on the benchmark 2-year
Treasury note more sensitive to changes
in Federal Reserve policy fell to one
point five to six percent which is five
basis points above the ten-year notes
rate of one point four seven six percent
after closing inverted on Monday before
August the last inversion of this part
of the yield curve was the one that
began in December 2005 two years before
the financial crisis and the subsequent
recession so there's pretty solid
information now that sometime in the
next couple of years the economy is
going to slow substantially and may be
dumped into recession now the Federal
Reserve has been pressured obviously by
President Trump in heavy ways to pump up
the the inflationary policy at the Fed
that of course is a bad idea as a
general rule I am not in favor
conservatives should not be in favor of
manipulation of the currency at the
Federal Reserve level they should not be
in favor of the central bank of the
United States effectively manipulating
interest rates they should not be in
favor of any of this because when the
Federal Reserve messes around with the
interest rates there is the significant
possibility that you are creating a
bubble that will then burst it is also
true that the Federal Reserve was
supposed to be apolitical their goal is
to be a backstop in case of emergency
there's supposed to be a 2007 2008
recession the Federal Reserve steps in
to cut interest rates and jog spending
for example it was not supposed to be
that a politician needs a lift and so
the Federal Reserve cuts rates in fact
the Federal Reserve was supposed to be
the responsible actor here and the fact
that President Trump is calling on the
Federal Reserve not to be responsible in
order to pump up the economy in advance
of the election is not a particularly
good thing and if a Democrat we're doing
this Republicans would rightly be
outraged
now does that mean that the Federal
Reserve should be acting politically no
it doesn't the theme of today's show is
going to be the failure of our
institutions and the fact that everyone
is losing faith in our institutions and
for good reason the politicization of
our institutions in every single
possible way is devastating to America's
social fabric to our trust in each other
if you cannot trust that our
institutions are going to run like they
are supposed to run then it's gonna be
very difficult to explain why we should
have delegated power to those
institutions in the first place maybe it
leads to a libertarian moment
alternatively maybe at least to tribal
warfare politics in which you don't care
about the institutions themselves and
maintaining the integrity of the
institution's themselves all you care
about is who's in control of the
government gun I'll get to all of this
in just one second this particularly
depressing message in just one second
but first I believe in gun ownership for
a variety of reasons I believe in gun
ownership because I care a lot about my
personal safety and the safety of my
family I care about gun ownership
because I believe that the Second
Amendment is a check against government
encroachments and all the other
amendments right now is your chance to
claim 19 free entries to win a gun from
the u.s. CCA responsible people should
own firearms and use them responsibly in
the u.s. CCA believes the same thing
this month in this month only they'll
get 19 free chances to win a thousand
bucks to buy a gun you've any gun you'd
like even a beautiful brand new Kimber
1911 just by texting in right now just
text the word win - 87 - 2 - and claim
your entries it really is that simple
u.s. concealed carry Association is
dedicated to providing world-class
self-defense education training and
legal protection to responsibly armed
Americans like you and like me their
mission is to provide you with the tools
and resources that you need to protect
yourself and your loved ones before
during and after a self-defense incident
I trust them to help me become a better
protector of my family you should trust
them as well
text win 287 - 2 - right now find out
more claim your 19 3 entries to win a
thousand bucks for a new gun again that
is text win 287 - - to WI n 287 - to the
u.s. CCA provides all sorts of great
resources to gun owners and potential
Gunners go check them out right now text
win - 87 - 2 - to check them out and
also to have that ability to be entered
to win a chance to win a thousand bucks
to buy any gun you want it's 87 - - to
win - 87 - 2 - ok so
with the economic backdrop that we
currently have as the backdrop there's a
report from the New York Times that
should undercut your faith in
institutions hey if the Federal Reserve
is supposed to be an impartial broker if
the Federal Reserve is supposed to be an
institution that stands apart from the
Hurley the hurdy-gurdy of everyday
politics well then this should be a
disquieting story according to the New
York Times the Fed could hit back at
Trump a former top official suggests
according to Gianna semiotic reporting
for the New York Times a former top
Federal Reserve official implied that
the central bank should consider
allowing president from strayed war to
hurt his 2020 election chances an
assertion that drew a firestorm of
criticism and rare pushback from the Fed
itself William Dudley is former
president of the Federal Reserve Bank of
New York he is now research scholar at
Princeton University and he said in a
Bloomberg opinion piece that president
Trump's re-election arguably presents a
threat to the US and global economy
totally added that if the goal of
monetary policy is to achieve the best
long-term economic outcome then Fed
officials should consider how their
decisions will affect the political
outcome in 2020 that's an astonishing
statement from the former president of
the Federal Reserve Bank of New York
he's openly stating now that the
officials at the Federal Reserve should
be attempting to tip the election to a
Democrat in order to help the economy
does that give you faith in the Federal
Reserve similarly should it give you
faith in the Federal Reserve if the Fed
Reserve Chairman were just taking orders
from the President of the United States
would that make you feel secure about
the safety and security of America's
economy this is a particularly
controversial statements as the New York
Times coming from an official who ranked
among the feds most powerful
policymakers and as recently as 2018 it
also comes at a sensitive moment for the
Fed which has been under attack from mr.
Trump and trying to assert its
independence from the White House in
politics in general Michelle Smith a Fed
spokeswoman said when asked about the
column quote the Federal Reserve's
policy decisions are guided solely by
its congressional mandate to maintain
price stability and maximum employment
political considerations play absolutely
no role but this is the problem with how
the Federal Reserve operates as a
general rule the fact is that the
Federal Reserve is constantly attempting
to tip balances for or against
particular executive policies pursued by
presidents of both parties really what
the Federal Reserve should be there to
do is to set a low steady interest rate
system
Friedman's point no infringements
suggested the Federal Reserve should set
a low steady interest rate and that
there should be basically they should
aim for maybe a 2% inflation rate every
year to jog the economy to keep people
spending but they should not be
inflating the currency wildly or
deflating the currency wildly and they
should be there in case of some sort of
catastrophic collapse this is the the
sort of Chicago School of Economics view
in order to ensure that currency doesn't
just disappear from the market place the
the Vienna the the Austrian School of
Economics would go even further they say
there should be no Federal Reserve you
should just peg the price of the dollar
to the price of gold and be done with it
there shouldn't be any government agency
that has involved creating the sort of
moral hazard that the Federal Reserve is
going to fix all problems with the
economy regardless but the Chicago
School of Economics and the Austrian
School of Economics would suggest that
the politicization of the Fed which did
happen under Franklin Delano Roosevelt
that the politicization of the pet and
the Fed the executive branch ordering
the Fed what to do or conversely the Fed
acting as an independent political agent
militate against a president of a
particular party that is going to
undermine your faith in Republican
institutions and it should and we are
watching this happen day in and day out
faith in each of our institutions it's
seemingly one by one is crumbling now
what that would theoretically suggest is
that what we need is for the
constitutional system of checks and
balances to kick in right well we would
need right now is if you don't have
faith in any one branch of the
government then you should have faith
that the entire government is going to
gridlock itself that you're not going to
sure we don't trust the executive branch
if you're a Democrat right now well
that's what the legislature is for and
you don't trust the legislature if
you're a republican well that's what the
executive branch is for you don't trust
the judiciary that's what the
legislature and the executive branch are
for you don't trust the federal
government in general that's what the
state governments are for right the
entire system of checks and balances
imposed by the founders assumed an
endemic level of mistrust in our
institutions so this is where the
Constitution really should become
valuable unfortunately there are a lot
of folks on both sides of the aisle but
particularly the left these days or
pushing against those checks and
balances at the same time we're losing
faith in the institutions so the
institutions no longer have our faith
and now they want to get rid of the
checks and balances so if you don't
trust the institutions and you don't
like the checks and balances what you're
really arguing for is taking control of
the institutions so you can use them
on behalf of your own favored policies
well that is very dangerous in Republic
basically that is two people that in
that turns government into the Joker's
game in the dark night splitting a pool
cue into and throwing it out there and
saying hey whoever controls the pool
pool cue gets to be employed here it
turns it into a tribal fight war by
other means as I suggested earlier this
week and pushing this are the folks of
the far left so Jamelle Bouie who is not
a very good columnist over the near
times he I am his work I will say that I
don't think that he thinks through a lot
of his own ideas he has an opinion piece
in The New York Times suggesting that
Alexandre Ocasio Cortez understands
democracy better than Republicans do
which is false AOC understands literally
nothing except for using Instagram
better than Republicans do and maybe
dancing on rooftops but that is a matter
of opinion
Jamelle Bouie says spend enough time
talking politics on the internet or in
any other public forum and you'll run
into this standard reply to anyone who
wants more democracy in American
government or a republic not a democracy
yes because that's true you saw it over
the weekends as Jamelle Bouie in an
exchange between representatives AOC and
tan Crenshaw of Texas friends adventure
show in a brief series of tweets Ocasio
Court has made the case against the
Electoral College and argued for a
national popular vote to choose the
president she said every vote should be
equal in America no matter who you are
or where you come from the right thing
to do is establish a popular vote and
GOP will do everything they can to fight
it Crenshaw has sparred with AOC before
jumped in with a response
abolishing the electoral college means
that politicians will only campaign in
and listen to urban areas that is not a
representative democracy he said we live
in a republic which means 51% of the
population doesn't get to boss around
the other 49% and then Jamelle Bouie
suggests that the crux of Crenshaw's
argument we live in a republic is wrong
he says he doesn't say not a democracy
but it's implied by the next clause
where he rejects majority rule you can
fill in the blanks of the argument from
there the founding fathers built a
government to stymie the tyranny of the
majority
they contrasted their republic with
democracy which they condemned as
dangerous and unstable as John Adams
wrote in an 1814 letter to the Virginia
politician John Taylor democracy never
lasts long
it soon wastes exhaust and murders
itself there never was a democracy yet
that did not commit suicide but there's
a
as Ginobili for the founders democracy
did not mean majority rule in a system
of representation the men who led the
revolution and devised the Constitution
were immersed in classical literature
and political theory ancient Greece in
particular was a cautionary tale
when James Madison critiqued democracy
in Federalist number 10 he meant the
Athenian sort a society consisting of a
small number of citizens who assemble
and administer the government in person
he says in more modern terms the
founders feared to rectum opera see and
accounted for its dangers with the
system of representative democracy yes
this republic had counter majoritarian
aspects but it was not designed for
minority rule nobody suggested that it
was designed for minority rule but if
Jamelle Bouie is truly suggesting that
the founders were big fans of pure
majoritarianism he hasn't read the
entirety of the Federalist Papers I'm
sorry Federalist ten isn't the only
Federalist paper that'll like eighty of
them so no that is incorrect the
Federalist Papers make quite clear that
they were that the founders were very
much afraid of faction they're afraid of
the power of majority to overrun the
rights guaranteed by the Constitution of
the United States the it's amazing to
see but we completely missed the point
like this is virtually everything was
geared toward producing representative
majorities that could govern on behalf
of the country to diminish faction in
favor of consensus and in the case of
the Electoral College the point wasn't
to stymie majorities but to provide a
way to find a competent and popular
chief executive in a large nation of
parochial states well it was to form a
electoral college majority out of a
plurality was probably one of the
purposes so it was to turn a minority
into a majority in some cases and when
it comes to producing representative
majority overwhelming majorities the key
founders were very much in favor of 51%
to 49% they were very much not in favor
of but again this is Jamelle Bouie
stumping against institutions of our
government that were designed to curb
our lack of faith in the institutions
themselves right so now he wants to get
rid of the checks and balances because a
o'seas argument could be made on exactly
the same basis for getting rid of the
United States Senate after all the
United States Senate gives the exact
same number of Representatives to
Montana which has like ten people as it
does to California which has 50 million
people so why shouldn't you make the
same argument about getting rid of the
Senate of the United States as it turns
out this isn't the only attack on
institutions that
Media are pushing they are also pushing
attacks on our very system of
immigration on borders at all we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about the uncertainty that we are
seeing right now springing from the
federal reserve springing from
international currency markets do you
feel uneasy with the fact that
policymakers across the world are now
relying on central banks to prop up
their economies with inflation and
deflation and raising interest rates and
lowering interest rates maybe you're
interested in investing in currency that
is not dependent on the vacillation of
central bankers who are now dependent on
the political whim of their masters in
governments all over the world well this
may be one reason that you want to
seriously consider including some
cryptocurrency in your profile and in
your portfolio cryptocurrency is
basically the digital equivalent of gold
what it is is a currency that is
protected by blockchain they're not
manufacturing more of it the idea is
that it holds value specifically because
you can't change it there's nobody who's
manipulating the currency eToro is smart
crypto trading made easy eToro social
trading platform has over 11 million
traders and facilitates over 1 trillion
dollars in trading volume per year
globally you can access the world's best
crypto currencies they've got 15
different coins available
they've got low and transparent fees try
it before you trade with a virtual
portfolio with a $100,000 budget never
miss a trading trend with charts and
pricing alert sign up today at eToro
comm slash Schapiro that is ET Oro comm
slash capiro eToro comm slash appear
I'll go check them out right now it's
really great cuz you can try it before
you can trade and that means that you
actually get experience with it see how
it works for you
eToro comm slash Shapiro that's eToro
comm slash apparel crypto may sound
intimidating but this is why you should
go give them a look over at eToro and
learn more eToro comm slash Shapiro ok
so it is not just an attempt to
undermine institutions like the
electoral college or the United States
Senate more and more Democrats are
suggesting the Senate is not
representative because obviously it's
not but it wasn't created to be
representative it was created to
manufacture of large-scale majorities
near super majorities in many cases in
order for the government to get anything
done specifically because the founders
feared that these institutions would not
be faithfully executed the solution for
a lot of folks on the left and some
people on the right too is that which
you just over run all those checks and
and really we should have an effective
government that gets things done the way
I want them done that is incredibly
dangerous your rights are protected by
the inability of the government to do
things that is what the founders thought
him and now you've got the New York
Times stumping not just against the
electoral college or the Senate you've
got them stumping against the very idea
of borders so the you New York Times
editorial board they're they're
wonderful editorial board they have an
editorial today called the immigration
system is a mess Trump's policies are
making it worse they say it has been an
eventful few weeks in president Trump's
ever escalating crusade to restrict
immigration on August 12th his
administration announced a rule change
making it more difficult for poor
immigrants to obtain green cards by
giving officials more leeway in
assessing who is likely to become a
public charge meaning someone who relies
on public services because it's good
policy
if you immigrate here and we think that
you're gonna be on welfare you shouldn't
be emigrating here on August 21st it
introduced a new rule jettisoning the
existing 20-day limit on holding migrant
children in detention that was designed
specifically so that we didn't have to
separate children from parents and also
so that we did not have to release
parents into the interior of the United
States where they show up for one court
hearing and then receive a provisional
green card and overstay that green card
and become permanent illegal residents
of the United States
the next day according to the New York
Times the president reasserted his
interest in abolishing birthright
citizenship the constitutional guarantee
that anyone born in the United States is
automatically a citizen they say
whatever its long-term implications the
president's obsession with what he has
termed an immigrant invasion is already
undermining the functioning of his
administration and the safety of the
nation the Boston Globe reported last
week a mass diversion of immigration
officers from New England to the
southwest border will bring to a stop
the processing of nearly all 40,000
asylum requests pending in New England
similarly back in March senior staff
members the US Citizenship and
Immigration Services
we're told that by year's end the agency
would shut down its international
division which assists overseas
applicants applying to immigrate to the
United States to redirect resources to
the border crisis as if the legal
immigration system needed additional
stressors okay so now you're just
objecting to Trump redirecting resources
so that we can enforce our southern
border I don't see you calling on
Democrats to provide additional funding
so we can continue doing all of these
thing
while ensuring safety and security at
our southern border what the New York
Times wants is catch and release what
the New York Times wants is catch and
release end of story
they want open borders they do not want
people who have entered the United
States illegally deported and they also
don't want people who are entering the
United States possibly illegally before
they're before their Asylum claims can
be adjudicated detained they simply want
an open border where people can walk
across disappearance the interior and
stay forever that is pretty much the
only way to read this editorial they say
they say the white house appears
ambivalent about the threat of white
supremacism earlier this month CNN
reported that for more than a year the
White House rebuffed efforts by Homeland
Security to make domestic terrorism a
strategic priority so now they're
suggesting that Trump is ignoring white
nationalism in favor of immigration
policy but our federal government spends
four trillion dollars a year it seems to
me they should be able to walk and chew
gum at the same time and if we are
talking about long-term effects on the
United States yes white nationalism is
evil it is a problem white supremacism
is a problem it is also a minut number
of people in absolute terms who are
providing an outsized threat as opposed
to you know if you are if you're just
talking about things that will affect
the country on a broad level for decades
to come
millions of people entering the country
illegally without any check and balance
is going to provide a pretty significant
change to the country now obviously that
change is going to come with good it's
gonna come with bad it's not an
unmitigated evil like white nationalism
or white supremacism of course of course
of course I'm not equated the two but
you suggest that the federal government
should spend all of its priority money
on fighting white nationalism and none
on the border is insane that's patently
crazy
the New York Times though again stumping
against the institution of having a
border that hey every president brings
into office a particular set of
principles and priorities but when those
biases start undercutting the
government's ability to pursue smart
policies or even carry out basic duties
a responsible leader must think less
about his personal prerogatives and more
about the nation's overall security
again I don't see the New York Times
ever covering it when an illegal
immigrant who has committed a crime goes
on to commit more crimes I mean the fact
is there are significant downsides
associated with not knowing who comes
into the country this is perfectly
obvious yes we should be spending more
money and more time and more resources
fighting white supremacist but this is
not
either/or choice at all it's patently
insane to suggest that it is
okay so we're busy undermining our faith
in the Federal Reserve
we're busy undermining our faith in the
checks and balances that would that
would stymie our lack of faith in these
various institutions we are undermining
basic policy that any country has to
enforce like having a border and now we
are talking about undermining the
credibility of the media that's supposed
to cover all of this and that the media
can do themselves they don't need any
outside actors doing that we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about losing your hair okay so male
pattern baldness runs in my family that
means I am deeply worried about losing
my hair lots of dudes are losing your
hair is no fun and two out of three
dudes will experience hair loss by the
time they are 35 which makes me nervous
since I am now 35 introducing keeps the
easiest and most affordable way to keep
the hair you have starting at just 10
bucks per month you'll never have to
worry about hair loss again getting
started is super easy signing up takes
less than five minutes just answer a few
simple questions snap some photos to
complete your online doctor consultation
a licensed physician will then review
your information online recommend the
right treatment for you it's shipped
directly to your door every three months
keeps treatments are up to 90% effective
at reducing and stopping further hair
loss it's only ten bucks to 35 bucks a
month plus right now you can get your
first month for free if you suffer from
hair loss the last thing you need is to
wait to see a doctor I mean you should
try it right now before you lose all
your hair with keeps there's finally a
way to get the help you need when you
need it for a limited time receive your
first month of treatment for free go to
keeps calm slash pen again if you suffer
from hair loss you can receive your
first month of treatment for free just
go to K EEP Escom slash Ben that's keeps
calm slash Ben go check it out right now
okay so the media another institution
that you would figure has to provide
some sort of check and balance so we no
longer trust the fed we apparently are
not going to trust the Electoral College
we're going to get rid of the checks and
balances so what would be the check and
balance on that well an honest media
right a media that covers that covers
the people in power without fear or
favor I've got some bad news for you
folks it turns out that our media are
not doing any of that it turns out that
our media are one-sided that our media
have been kissing the asses of Democrats
for literally my entire lifetime and
probably before well simultaneously
sporting the flimsiest speculative
evidence about Republicans today's
example comes courtesy of lawrence
O'Donnell so lawrence O'Donnell was on
MSNBC last night and he was with Rachel
Maddow who is happy to engage in
conspiracy theories particularly about
Russia and O'Donnell simply dumped out
there this idea that he has a source
inside Deutsche Bank
that said the president from loans were
underwritten by Russian billionaires
close to Vladimir Putin again this is
this this is now trending on Twitter
right hashtag Russian co-signers is now
trending on Twitter why because lawrence
O'Donnell said he has a 1:1 source a
secret source who says that Trump has
Russian co-signers now I'm just gonna
point out a quick double standard here
years back in his 2012 I was working at
Breitbart news and I reported a story
where I had a source and the tortoise
source suggested the chuck hagel than
the nominee for Secretary of Defense
under Barack Obama had spoken to a group
called friends of Hamas
it was a bad story we shouldn't run it
it was based on this single source it
was reported as a rumor
in fact I reported it exactly the same
way that lawrence O'Donnell did here and
I said this may not this may not be true
it's a rumor Hagel has refused to
respond all the rest of it I was
correctly excoriated for that ok the
story shouldn't have been reported you
shouldn't report rumors lawrence
O'Donnell says it on MSNBC not only is
it Linda dat lends an enormous amount of
credibility it's now trending on Twitter
as an absolute fact that this happened
here's lawrence O'Donnell
doing exactly what I was excoriated in
2012 for doing properly but doing it and
not only that being feeded for it here's
lawrence o'donnell just kind of spilling
out nonsense this single source close to
Deutsche Bank has told me that the Trump
Donald Trump's loan documents their show
that he has co-signers that's how he was
able to obtain those loans and that the
co-signers are Russian oligarchs but
really that would explain it seems to me
every kind word Donald Trump has ever
said about Russia and Vladimir Putin if
true and I stress the if true yeah
that's it that is a scenario that I have
never contemplated this it true if true
if true yes and then the media ran with
this okay I mean this is being widely
reported now there's no other evidence
to suggest this is true other than
Lawrence with Donald's word based on a
single source supposedly placed inside
Deutsche Bank we somehow has gotten hold
of Donald Trump's loan documents sure
sure now is trending on Twitter and
people are Trump will be impeached
because of this yes the undercutting
your own institutional credibility
believe me it didn't need Trump to call
you guys fake news in order for you to
destroy yourselves it's pretty
astonishing and there a bevy of examples
of this this week I mean they're just a
bevy of examples of the media
humiliating themselves today I mean not
even this week like in the last 24 hours
let me give you another example big
headline over at the Washington Post
William Barr books Trump's hotel for
$30,000 holiday party
that sounds bad or I mean it sounds like
the DOJ is spending money with the
president's hotel maybe in order to
curry favor with him or something it
doesn't sound good there's only one
problem hey here's the problem pretty
much the story's nonsense here's the
Washington Post reporting Attorney
General William P bar is planning a
holiday treat for his boss oh really is
that is that what he's doing it's a
holiday treat for Trump right last month
bar booked president Trump's DC hotel
for a 200-person holiday party in
December that is likely to deliver
Trump's business more than $30,000 in
revenue a bar signed a contract a copy
of which was obtained by the Washington
Post for a family holiday party in the
hotel presidential ballroom December 8th
the party will feature a buffet and a
four-hour open bar for about 200 people
okay then here is the actual crux of the
story bar is paying for the events
himself the DOJ is not covering any of
this no taxpayer dollars are being
expended on this also bar only chose the
venue after the other hotels in DC
including the Willard and the Mayflower
were booked according to the DOJ so it
wasn't like he went to Donald Trump was
like you know what I'm gonna slip 30
grand in your pocket here
first of all Trump Dupree rich in need
30 grand hey you didn't need to do more
than that I assume to bribe the
President of the United States to do
what exactly but apparently it's very
bad William Bart went to three separate
hotels the only one that had
availability the night that he wanted
was Trump's hotel which is a big hotel
in DC believe it or not there not a lot
of big hotels in Washington DC like in
the immediate area
if you ever stayed in Washington DC it
really is like two or three hotels all
the other hotels are
hole in the walls and small the official
said the purpose of bars party wasn't to
curry favor with the president well
clearly not because he could just pick
up the phone and kiss Trump's ass if he
wanted to curry favor with Trump
it ain't that difficult people do it on
Fox & Friends all the time really not
tough bar holds the bash annually okay
so it's not even like he does this it
regularly he has the party every single
year he went to two other hotels trying
to book it there they were both booked
so enter Trump's hotel and he's spending
the money out of his own pocket and by
the way this was cleared with the ethics
office the official said career ethics
officials were consulted they determined
that ethics rules did not prohibit him
from hosting his annual party at the
Trump Hotel okay but it didn't matter
this is on the front page of The
Washington Post the front obviously its
corruption I what man I we should
totally trust our media and then the
Washington Post had a piece yesterday
they ran an op-ed yesterday that is just
disastrously stupid the piece was by a
woman named Marisa bra Stav okay and it
was all about how the pro-life movement
is truly white supremacists which is
just absolute sheer garbage it is
absolute sheer garbage one of the chief
talking points of the pro-life movement
is that more black babies are aborted in
New York City every year than born
pro-life people want to see more babies
we do not care whether those babies are
black white or green this is ridiculous
I mean if if you were talking about the
pro-life movement being white
supremacists presumably they'd be very
much in favor of the continued access of
minority people to Planned Parenthood
because Planned Parenthood
disproportionately performs abortions on
ethnic minorities pro-life people have
been fighting against the eugenicist
movement for literally the entirety of
the pro-life movement Margaret Sanger
was a eugenicist a the founder of
Planned Parenthood she was a racist any
eugenicist yeah this is this is insane
okay but the Washington Post went even
further and running this op-ed okay this
op-ed originally included the following
paragraph you ready as bora controls
tighten the links between pronatal ISM
and nativism have once again become
visible inspired by Steve Kings admiring
remark about dirt vile ders is a
politician and then in the Netherlands
Iowa's Stewart creator of a popular
white nationalist blog called wife with
a purpose issued a white baby
challenged that went viral in all right
circles the mother of six asks audience
members to have as many white babies as
I have contributed hey that part is
idiotic but here is where it gets crazy
meanwhile as a replacement discourse
enters the conservative mainstream talk
of birth rates comes along with it our
people aren't having enough children to
replace themselves that should bother us
JD Vance author of the best-selling
hillbilly elegy told his audience at the
national conservatism conference last
month earlier this year he described
himself as a pulp by Democrats
permissive attitudes toward abortion
Vance did not need to spell out exactly
who Vance did not spell out exactly who
was included in the word our as in our
people he didn't need you no actually he
didn't need to because it turns out what
he was talking about was Americans he
said Americans need to be having more
babies why because it undercuts
America's culture not for Americans all
Americans not to have more babies
because it undercuts our economy not to
have a future generation of taxpayers
paying into our garbage upside down
pyramid schemes that's what he was
talking about but according to the
Washington Post
JD Vance is a vicious brutal racist for
no reason the Washington Post actually
had to cut it and then they didn't even
really issue a correction they just cut
the line yes I totally trust our media
another example of insane media bias
today there's a piece in The Washington
Post Washington Post really covering
itself in glory today there's a piece in
The Washington Post called a Harvard
freshman says he was denied entry to the
US over social media post made by his
friends it's by Deana Paul and Susan
Berg muga is myopia joey touched down at
Boston Logan International Airport on
Friday night prepared to begin his
freshman year at Harvard University the
17 year old Palestinian student never
left the airport the Harvard Crimson
reported US officials detained at shall
we for eight hours after interrogating
the minor and searching his phone and
computer they revoked his visa and sent
him home to Lebanon why according to a
statement by a shall we an immigration
officer claimed she found people posting
political points of view that opposed
the u.s. though she discovered nothing a
Chou he had posted himself a shall we
wrote after the five hours ended she
called me into a room and she started
screaming at me she said she found
people posting political points of view
that opposed the u.s. on my friends list
I responded I have no business with such
posts and I didn't like share or comment
on them and told her I shouldn't be held
responsible for what others
then the crimson reported a showers visa
was revoked and he returned to Lebanon a
shall we did not return any messages
from the post he can comment the Harvard
spokesman Jonathan Swain said in an
e-mailed statement that the university
is working closely with the family and
appropriate authorities to resolve the
matter Michael McCarthy is a spokesman
for CBP for Customs and Border
Protection
he said the department is responsible
for ensuring the safety and admissible
'ti of the goods and people entering the
u.s. applicants must demonstrate they
are admissible into the u.s. this
individuals deemed inadmissible based on
information discovered during the CBC
CBP inspection and the State Department
says visa records are kept confidential
under American law so we can't discuss
the details of individual cases so in
other words this story is solely based
on a Facebook account by a person who
will not return phone calls from the
Washington Post who has not turned over
his social media accounts to the
Washington Post and whose story cannot
be verified or disproved by CBP by law
but apparently this is indicative of the
Trump administration's at xenophobia
again solid reporting their guys really
really well done I'm sure that's the
entire story because I'm sure that a
person barred from the United States and
barred from their spot at Harvard
because CBP found something in the
profile I'm sure they would never ever
fib to the media or on Facebook ever now
maybe the whole story went down exactly
the way he said but certainly this story
does not provide sufficient evidence
that this should be reported that's
pretty insane but again they faith in
our institutions is declining at a rapid
rate as well it should be I'm gonna give
you another Washington Post story
covering himself in glory in just one
second this one I think is the height of
insanity first the daily wire has turned
four years old so congrats to us
Congrats to our employees who keep
getting paid as a thank-you to our fans
we are giving away one month of our
premium monthly subscription to anyone
who uses this code birthday magical for
all of August as we celebrate this
incredible milestone we've been giving
away a free first month for new premium
monthly subscribers again just use that
code birthday time is quickly running
out they're only three days left to get
this deal so subscribe today and come
join the fun also get that annual
subscription when you do you get this
the very greatest in beverage of vessels
it grants eternal life to you I mean
that's the pitch so far it has not yet
been disproved but you know let's put
that out
in the universe because I have a soy
source inside Deutsche Bank who says
it's true in any case leftist here's
Heinrich call tumblr you get that with
the annual subscription $9.99 a month
for 99 bucks a year which is cheaper
than $9.99 a month
look it up look it up do the math google
it in $9.99 a month or 99 bucks a year
check us out at daily wire.com we really
appreciate you joining the club we are
the fastest fastest-growing largest
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so it's not just that the media have
undermined institutional credibility in
themselves which they have in radical
fashion and the polls show it it's not
just that we have no real institutional
trust in the Institute the DOJ or the or
the Federal Reserve it's not just that
we've lost trust in the system of checks
and balances that keeps all of these
institutions in check now we are
undermining trust in the most basic
social institutions I'm talking about
the institution of family I'm talking
about institutions that are teaming
institutions they're just
presuppositions of a civil society like
language right like using terms in
common like logic you cannot have a
functional Republic or even a functional
democracy if we're not speaking the same
language we have basically devolved into
a Tower of Babel scenario so the left
decided that we were all going to move
in one universal direction it turns out
that human beings have different
priorities and so instead of us all
speaking the same language to build
something in common good or bad we have
now been devolved into this this insane
this this bizarre chaotic treatment of
language and logic that means that we
can never have a conversation with each
other again let me give you an example
of how we can never have a conversation
again this was a piece published on the
front page of The Washington Post
yesterday
the piece was titled to sum this queer
couple look straight for him that's okay
for her it feels like a lie again this
is published on the first page of the
Washington Post website by Samantha
Schmidt and Forrest Milbourne
so first you might be asking yourself
why is this being reported at all why
why is this a story that a person feels
uncomfortable person feels uncomfortable
is not a story in no media outlet worth
their salt would run a story with that
headline person feels uncomfortable with
self-definition
welcome to the world where lots of
people feel that way no this article is
about how society is cruel and mean
because it will not use a constantly
shifting standard for sex and gender
that makes everybody feel comfortable in
their own skin that's what this article
is truly about what you're about to hear
is an insane level of manipulation of
language that makes no logical sense
there's no common standard no logical
sense no internal structure and yet if
you don't buy into the idea that words
can
randomly change chimerical shift
shapeshifters they can just move around
then that's because you are bad so now
we're undermining human language it's
not just enough to undermine the Federal
Reserve or undermine or undermine the
media now the media are busily
undermining you know basic human
language ability to communicate with
each other because after you read this
piece you'll be so confused you never
want to read another piece hey here we
go when Kate Murray and Andy Arnold
first started dating in their early
twenties they were part of a tight-knit
group of lesbian friends in the district
the couple and their friends hung out
almost every weekend organizing potluck
dinners and frequenting ladies nights at
local gay bars then about two years ago
and it came out as a transgender man and
as he transitioned with Kate support the
couple suddenly felt they no longer
belonged in the women's centric spaces
they were used to they tried testing out
a new group of friends a blank slate a
group in which Andy wouldn't have to
talk about his trans identity he said he
could just blend in as a man to the new
friends they were just Andi and Kate a
man dating a woman and that was just
telling and he liked it but to Kate it
felt like a lie she wants to express her
queer identity she said but how could
she do that without making Andy
uncomfortable okay so we have two
conflicts of vision here and the one
vision you have a lesbian who wants to
be known as a lesbian because she feels
like it's a part of her identity to be a
lesbian and she's dating a biological
woman so that would seem to fit the
criteria on the other hand we have a
society in the media that suggests that
if a biological woman has surgeries and
hormone treatments and believes that she
is a man that she is now a man which
means that the formerly lesbian woman is
actually straight because she is a
lesbian she's a woman who is dating a
man right by so by biological definition
Kate is right so if she uses normal
definitions of sex you know the ones
we've been using for all of you in
history then Kate is correct but she's
also insensitive and cruel because then
she'd think like I am right so instead
the media are purporting to provide this
view that Andy's an actual man which
means that Kate is straight so who's
intolerant is Kate intolerance because
Kate doesn't consider Andy an actual man
or as anyons hollering because he
doesn't consider Kate natural lesbian
which one is it
The Washington Post answer society is
intolerant all right so it's a it's it's
a it's you you're you reading the story
you we are in town
because we're looking at this and we
thought that this is a pretty binary
question right either Andy's a man or
Andy's woman I mean there are no other
choices here there's no other choice on
the board either and he's a man or a
woman
I wasn't standard the crazy left media
insane gender studies Bizzaro standard
Andy is man
which means Kate is straight by the
biological definition and he's a woman
which means Kate's a lesbian those are
the only two choices nah you thought
that this was a logical Kobayashi Maru
problem wrong that you are William
Shatner here has found a way out of the
Kobayashi Maru problem his solution is
you're the bigot for reading the story
and believing in logic and language and
wait for it wait for it okay for the
couple who are now engaged to be married
there are no clear answers to this Andy
said no matter how much I want to
separate my trans identity from Who I am
I can't I can't separate it from my
relationship with Kate because she's a
queer woman it's a daily dance we
navigate this tension is a daily reality
for many queer couples who feel the way
others perceive them is it odds with who
they really are that's the sentence
right there right it's a daily reality
for queer couples who feel that the way
others perceive them is at odds with
could they it's you you're not
understanding enough you with your logic
in your language and your definitions
you're intolerant you're undercutting
both Andi and Kate who lead a happy life
if you would simultaneously agree that
Kate is a lesbian and also the Andy is a
man how dare you how dare you sir this
is just ridiculous and then the article
talks about how Andy is quote unquote
passing but Andy isn't really passing
because Andy is a man or is Andy a man
unclear right Andy says I want to be
seen as a man I don't want to have any
sort of mark on me that says I'm trans I
think if I were more inclined to do that
Kate and I would probably have an easier
time some people do feel like I need to
represent the group I'm a part of but
not me I just want to blend and then the
Washington Post really drops the hammer
again it's about you right so this
bizarre situation that clearly exposes
the flaws in gender studies thinking
it's problem with you many Americans
still have a hard time grasping the fact
that gender and sexual orientation are
independent from each other a person's
gender identity does not determine whom
they will be attracted to or who will be
attracted to them see
you're the bigot now again this article
has nothing to do with that sort of
confusion at all at all right but it's
about you and your intolerance
transgender and non-binary people
identify as genders different from those
on their birth certificates but for
example a transgender man might be
attracted only to women or only to men
or both it depends entirely on the
person and when a person transitions
while in a relationship it doesn't
necessarily change their partner's
sexual orientation just because Cait is
no longer dating a woman doesn't mean
she is no longer queer distinguishing
between identities in the LGBTQ
community has become increasingly
complex as more categories for gender
identities and sexual orientations have
emerged many of them breaking with
traditional non buying it with
traditional binary notions terms such as
pansexual have emerged to describe
people who are attracted to frying pans
oh no no that's sorry pansexual have
emerged to describe people who are
attracted to a full spectrum of gender
identities it's a double-edged swords as
the Washington Post okay so if your
faith in your ability to understand
human language has been undercut that
would be the point that would be the
point it's just all of this is insanity
but it doesn't stop there
because all of this is really in the end
this is designed to reduce all of life
into subjectivism it's designed to
reduce life into all of all of life into
subjectivism once all of life is reduced
to subjectivism that the only true
happiness can be found within because
reason and logic go out the window
because you really can't control your
own behavior subjectivism is the only
thing that counts well if the only thing
that matters is your subjective pleasure
your subjective self definition then you
are going to identify as a member of a
tribe with people who think like you and
then politics just becomes a question of
tribal warfare how does your tribe
empower over another tribe and that is
exactly what politics is becoming
because it used to be you could have a
conversation with somebody who disagreed
now conversations with people who
disagree with you are considered
verboten
they're considered bad and wrong by the
left how do I know this well tell you a
brief story so just a few weeks ago I
was in a room with a with a dude who
happens to be I'm not gonna name him I'm
not gonna name the podcast haven't you
very prominent on an extremely popular
left-wing podcast friendly guy right we
got to talking we obviously just
on a wide variety of things and I said
to him you know what should do we should
do a crossover podcast cuz your podcast
is popular and my podcast is popular
you'll get huge audiences it'd be really
interesting it could show the
conversation is still possible and he
said to me your audience would be fine
with it I said I know my audience would
be fine with it because my audience
doesn't care if I have a conversation
with somebody on the other side in fact
when we do my Sunday special every week
I have conversations with people on the
other side probably thirty five percent
to forty five to forty percent of the
time everybody from Andrew yang to Piers
Morgan right do it all the time
Larry Woolmer we do it a lot I'm happy
to have conversations with people on the
other side of the aisle see what he said
was my audience would kill me he said my
audience would not allow you in the room
they would kill me okay and that is it
that's correct that's what politics has
come down to so why should I trust a
political system that allows that guy in
his audience to dominate me why would I
possibly be in favor of that and that's
what a lot of folks on the radical left
would like at this point not a
conversation not a system of checks and
balances that requires a supermajority
of Americans or a heavy majority of
Americans to agree to something to
change the system which seems proper in
a diverse for public now instead what
they want is sheer power politics and
they want to indoctrinate your kids into
all of this and that there's an article
at The Huffington Post that I think is
pretty telling along these lines by Lucy
Rimmel our is my kid fluent in racism so
now we're talking about the
indoctrination of children into this
particular belief system radical
subjectivism a belief that American
history is awful and evil a belief that
we can't have conversations with each
other that we have to change human
language in order to mirror your your
personal preferences the article is that
huffington post the repository of all
things stupid does my three-year-old has
an uncanny ability to bust me on curse
words the whole ride home from school he
ignores my questions about his day
dinner preference his upcoming
activities but then sure is bleep
what did you say mommy he asked sweetly
oh I was talking about a thing I
stammered no mommy what did you say
about that man in the parking lot he
persists he's referring to when I
expletive about a man blocking a busy
parking lot I'll but I'm far more
concerned about the foul racist language
he's going to encounter I'm not talking
about Trump's racist tweets or comments
these crimes are the headline where I
feel out of my depth as
parents is the insidious heavily by a
storytelling that I won't always be able
to interpret for my son the language of
the news
it says not merely that we're gonna
twist language now is that we're going
to indoctrinate children in the twisting
of language she says when news stories
describe latinx asylum seekers as
illegal aliens or refer to African
American protesters seeking social
justice as thugs that becomes the
hateful way the kids see latinx and
african-american people perhaps
including themselves okay so just to get
this straight if you legally immigrated
to the United States and you are not
properly an asylum seeker which is the
vast majority of people who apply for
asylum in the United States then it's
racist to refer to you as an illegal
immigrant and here's the example this
woman used you ready when the 1992 Los
Angeles Riots happened I was 13 years
old living in LA suburb I remember this
too I was eight years old living in an
LA suburb she says I was glued to the TV
along with my parents my brothers and
everyone else I knew the lens from my
experience was not the unjust acquittal
of the four officers who beat Rodney
King no one on the local news was
talking about social justice they were
talking about looters and violent people
burning down our city yes because that's
what the LA riots were literally people
running out into the street bashing in
store windows stealing TVs and beating
the living hell out of truckers who got
caught in the middle of the area Korean
shop owners were perched out on top of
their stores with rifles to protect
their own property the LA riots were a
horror show you want to protest the
Rodney King verdict go for it that's not
what the LA riots were they were riots
and a lot of the people taking part in
them or people who are looking to steal
a TV that is just the reality of the
situation it was not in LA uprising it
was not a politically motivated
quote-unquote uprising against against
authorities if it were it would have
been directed at the mayor's office
which is in downtown LA that is not what
happened but apparently if you called
the riots what they were then this is an
element of bigotry and racism so we are
we are devolving into a society where
you can't even have a common
conversation which of course undermines
the faith in the institutions but then
also you don't want the institutions of
checks and balances to stop you from
beating up the other guy so you want to
get rid of the checks and balances you
want institutions that you can't trust
unless you control them this is how you
get to tyranny pretty quickly and this
how you got to people who don't want to
have a conversation with anybody living
in the same country with
on the other side but desperately wants
you crammed down there policy
preferences on people on the other side
of the aisle and it's this is not going
to end well in any way shape or form
it's gonna get worse and worse unless
people come back to the table and start
having conversations again but I don't
think those conversations are possible
in in our current political climate
that's for damn sure okay
we can do a quick thing I like and then
a quick thing that I hate so a thing
that I like I have to admit I laughed
really hard at this so Bernie Sanders
apparently was speaking in Louisville
Kentucky when he stopped by the hum and
Muhammad Ali museum le of course the
greatest heavyweight boxer of all time
and Bernie Sanders decided that he was
going to take a turn on the speed bag
now as somebody who exercises frequently
I am NOT a person who is great with the
speed bag in the gym but you actually
have to practice with it Bernie Sanders
apparently thought that he could get
away with this it did not go well for
him you should subscribe just to see
this clip he hits the speed bag it comes
back at him and it nearly knocked him
out nearly gets Kayode by the speed bag
which makes sense because if the speed
bag is logic then Bernie Sanders getting
kod hits the he hits the logic the logic
comes right back at him and he gets I
mean the wild overreaction Bernie
Sanders almost breaking a hip here
that's that's some pretty spectacular
stuff I would say that Bernie Sanders
you know that that is the only thing he
is worse at than punching a speed bag
apparently and then jabbing at a speed
bag like an octogenarian because he is
one is his take on China
so this transitions into things I hate
but we'll just do it right here here's
Bernie Sanders yesterday suggesting that
China has done a wonderful job of levy
ating poverty as though communism and
socialism are responsible for that and
not the market capitalism the free
market capitalism that the Chinese
authoritarian regime has taken part in
at least partially it was that embrace
of open markets and free trade that
allowed China to raise a billion people
from poverty in 30 years because before
that China had a different way of
alleviating poverty that was kill 40
million people in the Great Leap Forward
I think China is a country that is
moving unfortunately in a more
authoritarian way in a number of there
actions we would have hoped that they
would move toward a democratic more
democratic form of government and moving
in the opposite direction but what we
have to say about China in fairness to
China and its leadership is if I'm not
mistaken they have made more progress in
addressing extreme poverty than any
country in the history of civilization
good for them Bernie Sanders had you
loves him some some communist
authoritarianism again there's only one
problem which is that the reason that
poverty was alleviated in China has
nothing to do with the communism and
everything to do with embracing free
trade that literally everything to do
with opening itself up to different
markets and embracing in capitalist
commerce right that's what Deng is 'm
was it was the the the emphasis on
practicality over communist doctrine now
shishun pang is trying to reverse a lot
of that stuff okay time for a quick
thing that I hate so speaking of the
media undercutting its own credibility
there is something deeply amusing about
Chris Matthews on MSNBC complaining
about the dirt bag politics dirt ball
politics of digging up people's old
tweets and using them against them I'm
pretty sure this is what MSNBC does at
the behest of Media Matters on a
near-daily basis here's Chris Matthews
saying it's just terrible people digging
up stuff on journalists what are they
gonna find about me and coming in here
my Herald run pulled every morning run
line in here don't even prepare for the
show just jabber on about random things
and what are they gonna find I meant you
remember that time added tingle up my
leg about Obama I hope that I'm fine
what I was doing backstage that's weird
let's talk about the dirtbag politics of
digging up bad stuff on people which we
do daily let's go
dirt ball politics where do you catch
this Trump a lot allies are out
unleashing dogs on journalists now point
together Oppo research and compiling
dossiers a potentially embarrassing
social media post on an attempt to try
to discredit intimidate whatever chill
reporters he wants their media to stop
reporting on him objectively so they're
going out up to people's families people
work for them in their corporate in
their organizations anything to stop
people from reporting on him this is
exactly what Joe McCarthy did it's
exactly what Joe McCarthy didn't we do
it also but it's bad when they do it
it's really really good and we do
because we're speaking truth to power
this is very reminiscent of
folks on the left decides to redefine
racism so that racism isn't just bigotry
against another racial group
it is bigotry combined with power this
allows the left to redefine racism so
that if somebody who is black is racist
they're not racist because they don't
have power right Sevilla huh Nomar ends
up being anti-semitic she's not actually
a bigot because she doesn't have enough
endemic institutional power right that
very much like this this isn't the media
saying very bad when they do it very
good and read to it it's pretty
spectacular if I decide to dig up
people's old tweets that's just
something I do over here but if you dig
up an old tweet about how much I wanted
to massage Barack Obama's foot that's
awkward for me I don't like it very much
you're trying to undercut my objective
journalism so objective pot yeah good
stuff media we definitely will continue
to trust you and get one more quick
thing that I hate so beta or work
demonstrating again that if you ask a
democratic question about abortion
things get supremely ugly so the fellow
who actually asked me to work this
question called in to our radio show
yesterday and told us this story pretty
simple question bait Oh blows it like a
like a like a marijuana like a doobie
like I do
here's beta going for it my question is
this I was born September 8 1989 and I
want to know if you think on September
7th 1981 89 my life had no value
of course I don't think that and of
course I'm glad that you're here but you
you reference my answer in in Ohio and
it remains the same this is a decision
that neither you nor I nor the United
States government should be making
that's a decision for the woman to make
so in other words I'm glad you're here
but also if your mom had killed you the
day before you were born
oh yeah then I guess it wouldn't be here
asking me this awkward question would
you that would make my life a lot easier
by the way I think what we've all
learned from this particular segment is
I really need to get up on my drug
vernacular because it is not strong all
right II will be later we will be here
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Stevens audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you